soon after 1930 the deaths from lung
cancer turn sharply upwards
by 1980 if the present rate continues
there will be 90 000 deaths per year
or will there
today
physicians are increasingly doing the
things that can reduce this mortality
and make a different story possible
by pre-operative selection of
potentially favorable lesions
we have experienced
a four-fold increase in the overall
survival from bronchogenic carcinoma
there is no question in my mind
that pre-cancerous lesions from smoking
are reversible
today it is increasingly important for
all physicians to have an aggressive
attitude about this disease
because the cure rates can be further
improved
early thoracotomy is indicated in all
new lesions which defy the usual methods
of diagnosis
these small asymptomatic tumors have the
best prognosis
here is the photograph of a normal lung
in a non-smoker
and here is the photograph of a lung
cancer in a man who has smoked most of
his adult life
after a study of some
1972 autopsies at our hospital
we are able to determine when a man has
smoked heavily
over a long period of time
we are also able to determine
when a heavy cigarette smoker has given
up the habit for a considerable period
of time
prior to his death
normal bronchial epithelium consists of
a layer of ciliated columnar cells
beneath it is a layer of one or two
basal cells of uniform size
with small evenly staining nuclei
the basal cells lie on a basement
membrane
early changes toward malignancy can be
recognized where there is a conspicuous
and abnormal increase
in the number of basal cells with
numerous atypical nuclei
carcinoma in situ
is characterized by the fact that there
is an easily identified increase of the
basal cells
resulting in a thickening of the
epithelium
of five or more rows
and the absence of cilia
there is as yet no invasion of the
basement membrane
all of the cells are atypical with
prominent hyperchromatic nuclei
with an early invasive bronchogenic
carcinoma
there is an extensive cellular atypism
and extension beyond the basement
membrane
even at the slight stage of development
the lesion is not large enough to be
seen in the x-ray
nor is it large enough to produce any
clinical symptoms
now let us see how the process reverses
itself
when the individual has given up smoking
here is an example
of an individual who had smoked two
packs of cigarettes a day for 20 years
and had given up the habit for five
in a recent study we found that cells
with atypical nuclei were present in
only 1.2 percent of the slides from
those who had never smoked regularly
compared with ninety three percent among
slides from those who were smokers up to
the time of their last illness
among those who had smoked for at least
ten years but not within five years
prior to death
there were only six percent of the
slides with cells with atypical nuclei
perhaps the greatest motivation
for patients to give up the habit of
smoking
lies in the fact that the process is
reversible
certainly it is the responsibility of
physicians to discourage their patients
from smoking however the more immediate
problem is the management of patients
who have lung cancer or are in the high
risk group
periodic chest x-ray is the most widely
available and simplest method for the
detection of lung cancer
routine films on asymptomatic patients
particularly on smokers besides
disclosing unsuspected lesions serve as
a valuable purpose for future baseline
of comparisons
is the early diagnosis of lung cancer
really worthwhile when the national
average is less than 10 percent in
overall survival
the answer very definitely is yes
i would like to illustrate several
points that are very important in the
management of lung cancer with some
chest x-rays this first patient
represents an early diagnosis and
represents the value of the baseline
film
this film of several years ago was
normal
we then have a film that was taken about
two years later and this was also called
however because this was a heavy smoker
and because of suspicion of pulmonary
pathology an additional film was taken
six months later and at that time for
the first time
a small density less than one cm in
diameter was found
hidden in part by this rib
as we looked back at the film of six
months ago we could see the genesis of
this lesion
this patient had a conventional
diagnostic workup and following that a
right upper lobectomy
and
we see here the rib resection and the
result of lobectomy and the expansion of
the remaining lung to fill up the space
of the lobe that was removed
this patient lived more than five years
i would like to be able to say that
early diagnosis of this nature is the
complete answer to lung cancer
it does
improve curability but there are some
lesions that are so biologically
unfavorable that in spite of everything
we do
we still cannot obtain survival for the
patient
this next series of films for example
illustrates that point
first we have a chest x-ray with a
rather subtle lesion above the right
hilar root and again in part behind the
rib
however this is recognized and thought
to be suspicious enough to warrant
further investigation
the bronchogram was done demonstrating
obstruction of the bronchial going to
the particular area in suspicion
then finally the lesion was found to be
inoperable
and the patient was dead of his disease
within a matter of three or four months
in spite of the fact that this is a very
small lesion
while we have been stressing the
importance of lesions of small size this
case illustrates another point and that
is the location of the tumor when they
are placed centrally and close to the
mediastinum
they rapidly metastasize to the
mediastinal nodes and become inoperable
thus the patient has prevented an
opportunity of a cure even when the
lesion is small
this again illustrates the inherent
biological potential of certain types of
lung cancer which make it such an
unfavorable disease in contrast to other
forms of cancer it also emphasizes the
necessity of prevention
there is another type of situation for
which we must be alert this is the time
when pneumonia masks a lung cancer and
may prevent its diagnosis
this lady had recurrent attacks of
bronchitis over a period of years and
they responded to antibiotics and
customary therapy however on one
occasion a lesion appeared in the region
of the lingula of her left upper lobe
and this persisted more than two weeks
under antibiotic therapy it not only
didn't go away but its margins became
more distinct and sharper and this led
to the suspicion that it might be a
carcinoma
further studies were made as is our
custom and finally the patient was
submitted to exploratory thoracotomy and
lobectomy this proved to be an alveolar
cell carcinoma of relatively small size
without lymph node metastasis and she is
alive and well many years later
in addition to the problem of pneumonia
there are other diseases that may cover
lung cancer and obscure it
this particular patient had a cavity in
his right upper lobe it doesn't look
particularly like tuberculosis yet this
must be considered in the differential
diagnosis
however the right hilar root is rather
heavy and there is some lower low
pulmonary fibrosis this patient was
explored and proved to have an
inoperable lung cancer
any lung shadow that persists more than
two weeks warrants suspicion of cancer
and further diagnostic procedures should
be undertaken at once
among other x-ray diagnostic tools is
fluoroscopy which allows one to observe
the pulmonary dynamics
bronchography may outline a small
obstruction
tomography that is body section
genography may reveal additional details
early exploratory thoracotomy is
indicated whenever the diagnosis is in
question or when endoscopic evaluation
indicates that a curative resection is
feasible the fourth lar economy
each patient should be carefully
evaluated
in order to delineate the nature of the
lesion and its extent
as well as the patient's cardiopulmonary
reserve
sputum cytology is an integral part of
this diagnostic evaluation
in the poor risk patient it may be the
only means of safely establishing the
diagnosis
when positive it not only reinforces the
diagnostic suspicion
and the indication for exploration
that allows the surgeon to proceed with
a definitive resection
the time of thoracotomy without risking
spread of the lesion by operative biopsy
bronchoscopy is another important
diagnostic procedure
it may visualize a centrally located
lesion
a right angle telescope increases the
extent of this observation
bronchoscopy may provide diagnostic
tissue
or cytologic washings
findings at bronchoscopy
help define resectability
we have almost routinely performed
scalene lymph node biopsy at the time of
bronchoscopy
it has yielded positive nodes in one
quarter of our patients
these are in our opinion
criteria of inoperability
mediastinoscopy an extension of node
sampling to within the mediastinum may
be helpful
in establishing a diagnosis and in
determining operability
the scope is passed into the mediastinum
through a cervical incision
and nodes along the trachea carina and
main stem bronchi are visualized and
biopsied as indicated
involvement of the laryngeal nerve
superior vena
cava or distant metastases
or other criteria which usually indicate
inoperability
however superior sulcus tumors invading
the apex of the thorax have on occasion
responded favorably to combined
resection and radiation therapy
exploratory thoracotomy is performed in
the absence of the above mentioned
criteria of inoperability
and resection is offered to all patients
without mediastinal spread or
significant chest wall invasion
it is unquestionably the surest way of
arriving at a definitive diagnosis
and hopefully affecting cure
by proceeding with a definitive
resection
lobectomy
is the operation of choice in
bronchogenic carcinoma when the tumor is
confined to the low
pneumonectomy is performed when the
tumor crosses the fissure or when the
associated interlobar or hylar lymph
nodes are involved
pneumonectomy is usually performed
intrapericardially
in order to obtain a wider vascular
margin with an n block resection of
involved lymph nodes
extended resection of mediastinal nodes
chest wall
and contiguous vascular structures
is reserved for the younger patients who
are better able to tolerate the
increased morbidity of the procedure
the factor which has the greatest
influence upon survival is the size of
the legion
our experience indicates the favorable
nature of lesions
of three centimeters or less confined to
one lobe
what can we offer to the patient whose
lung cancer is inoperable or in whom
surgery cannot remove all of the disease
radiation therapy is a valuable adjunct
in the management of lung cancer
in fact a cure can be affected in a
small but definite number of patients
there are some situations where its
intelligent and judicious use can
control certain symptoms such as
hemorrhage infection behind obstruction
and particularly of pain
there are some special situations such
as superior sulcus tumors superior vena
caval syndrome and plural effusions
where effective control can be obtained
by radiation
pre-operative irradiation is being
evaluated today in a number of
institutions and the final answer on it
is not yet in
chemotherapy
plays a limited role in the management
of lung cancer in contrast to other
forms of disseminated cancer
however there are some special
situations where it may be of
value the surgical curability of lung
cancer was demonstrated more than 30
years ago
since that time we have learned much
about its prevention and also about its
diagnosis and treatment
the fate of the individual patient
frequently depends upon the prompt and
full application of this knowledge
you